people think that the federal government
has any power except things that are
expressly prohibited and it's actually
the other way around I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin report here's my
friendly reminder to click subscribe and
also click that little bell if you're
watching this on YouTube so that you
actually get notified of our videos ok
now joining me today is a lawyer and the
author of several books including the
indispensable electoral college how the
founders plan saves our country from mob
rule
tariffs welcome to the Rubin report
thanks for having me I am glad to have
you here you you actually live in Dallas
and you sort of just missed this crazy
tornado situation so I'm doubly glad
that you made it yeah ok good to have
you here we're gonna focus heavily on
the electoral college because there's a
lot to talk about the electoral college
I became familiar with you because
you're Prager you video has 60 million
views about the electoral college that
is crazy that that many people care we
were you shocked but that many people
care about a topic I mean it's their
number one video it came out before the
election probably a good year and a half
before the 2016 election and I didn't
really think about it I mean just to be
honest then the 2016 election happened
and next thing I know I'm pulling up on
my Facebook feed and my sister's oh my
god never again and my friend feeds for
my friends and I i i was as blown away
as anybody else but i think that you
know Prager has setup a good system
where they have informational videos and
all these different topics as you know
and people were looking for information
in the wake of the election outcome in
2016 and that was readily available and
I'm so happy so happy that Prager did it
yeah and as we've now ramp into this
2020 election this conversation about
should we have an electoral college why
do we have it should it be popular vote
this whole thing keeps ramping up more
and more so we're going to spend most of
our conversation talking about that but
I thought we just start generally
talking about the Constitution and some
of the laws that govern us these days
because people seem very confused about
them tell me a little bit about
something that we don't know about
a constitution that we should know the
first thing that left in my mind was
people think that the federal government
has any power except things that are
expressly prohibited and it's actually
the other way around the federal
government only has the power that the
Constitution expressly gives to it
everything else is reserved to the
states or the people and if you think
about that that's a really important
distinction the federal government can
only do what the Constitution explicitly
says yes you may do this and the federal
government has grown so out of bounds
that it's you know it's doing the
opposite every day it does the opposite
yeah well it seems that that's how we're
governed now that almost everything is
through the federal government and
especially if you listen to the
Democratic candidates now that they seem
to want to do all of these things
regardless of what States wants and
things like that how do they get away
with it I don't mean to make this even
partisan in general speaking I say both
parties do do I I don't I think it
starts with us honestly because think
about anything that's happening if you a
financial disaster hits a tornado in
Dallas yeah
people hopefully in Texas a little bit
less at the Texas girl yeah we look to
the government and we look we don't look
to even to the state government we look
to the federal government we want our
governor to declare a state emergency
because then we know there's more
federal funds there's more this there's
more that I think the mindsets of ever
everybody has changed so badly that
we're enabling the situation to continue
so maybe we can start at home by look
I'm you know I'm from Dallas I'm what I
hope we all we're pitching in we're
helping our neighbors we're hopefully
looking to our state or our city before
we start looking to the federal
government I think that if we can work
on that that's a really big problem I
just outlined yeah but well are you
shocked it sort of how little it seems
people know or care about our founding
documents I mean I talk about them here
all the time the Constitution and the
Declaration of Independence are sitting
on the wall in my control room right
over there but that so few people
actually really think about the
documents that led to the unprecedented
freedom that we're living in right now
we live in a world that has created that
we have schools that teach social
studies when they used to teach history
you know we don't teach the Federalist
Papers which of course were the in the
anti-federalist papers which were the
arguments back and forth at the time of
the founding about the Constitution and
why it exists as it does and what what
they were trying to create we just we
don't do any of this stuff in our
schools anymore and then we have adults
that grow up having never been exposed
to this and and so nobody knows
literally nobody knows and I think the
founding generation if you read in the
Federalist Papers especially over and
over and over again
James Madison or Alexander Hamilton will
say the people will keep this in line
they and they talk about the people as
if we will be educated as if we will
know as if we will take all of this into
consideration when we're voting and
doing all the things that we do but once
you undermine education and once that's
gone how can you possibly keep the
structure in place anymore do you think
that was a miscalculation by the
founders that over time sort of that the
state would kind of slowly grow and then
as it grew that education would kind of
get worse and maybe they couldn't
envision all of that but that that was
their miscalculation that the people
would somehow always be engaged yes I
did they knew they assumed the people
would be engaged you read it over and
over again they also assumed we would
always be more loyal to our state's than
to the federal government which probably
by the way comes with the education when
you educate you lose the loyalty to your
States because you stop understanding
why it's so important why that's an
important part of the check system of
checks and balances yeah we talked about
the executive and the judiciary and the
legislative and how they work against it
and with each other and how they check
and balance each other but also the
state and the federal government we're
supposed to be checks on each other and
that doesn't mean States always handle
things correctly just like the federal
government doesn't handle things
correctly but it's all a part of the
process we assume that everybody's gonna
make mistakes we assume that the system
where there are so many competing powers
going head-to-head all the time that
that will in the end protect us because
everything will be it will be difficult
to push anything through too quickly and
in the the heat of the moment
emotionally and isn't that sort of the
bizarre situation we're in we're now
it's like we've had this incredible
system where the states could tinker and
figure out what they wanted to do with
taxes and education and gay marriage
marijuana legalization and literally
every topic there is but now we're
outsourcing all of that and it's like
well now if the government does some bad
stuff it's not that you can leave your
state because the next day it's gonna be
the same you got to leave the country
right that's not good that's not good I
mean when you were talking about that I
was thinking there's so many examples
from history where Wyoming for instance
was the very first state to let women
vote they did it in 1892 way before
anybody else because they thought it was
a good idea the reason was funny they
want to buy it more pioneers women to
come out join all the men there were too
many men and they needed women but
states used to operate for themselves
with their own interest in mind and they
made decisions on all sorts of topics
and we don't even consider that anymore
so we're here we're here in California
which is probably doing most of that
wrong and we have an ever-expanding
government and we now have a you know
this progressive governor Newsom but
you're in Texas what are some of the
things that you think maybe Texas which
is still a little more Texas that Texas
might be doing right that maybe
California is doing wrong I mean I love
my state we're not perfect so I can also
list things were doing wrong sure but um
all right well let's do both good oh
well you can't buy a Tesla straight from
from the you have to go through all
these hoops because of the automobile
lobby from what I understand mm-hmm
there are there are things that I think
are not great but mostly what we do is
we regulate less you know if you
couldn't use a straw use a straw if you
don't want to use a straw don't use this
truck so funny you say that because I
was telling you I was just in Dallas
this past weekend and you guys still
have plastic straws we like them and I
was in New York a couple days before
drinking out of this soggy straw and I'm
like this is horrible I know it's a bit
look there's arguments for and against
it whatever I'm not trying to diss
anybody's opinion on that but it just in
Texas I think we are probably more
likely not uniformly but more likely to
say make your own decision we have fewer
taxes which I consider a great thing you
know there's no income tax but we do
have property taxes but you choose to
buy a house and then you pay the
property tax when you choose to buy the
house I hope that we're a little bit
more free down there just to kind of
make up our minds but
I think the founders would have liked
that they definitely would have liked
that so so right now we're seeing what I
think are major assault particularly on
the First Amendment so we'll start with
that particularly on on free speech now
people are very confused about
encroachments on free speech relative to
the government versus just sort of mob
rule that we see all the time
are you well do you agree with me that
free speech really is in a tenuous state
that maybe it hasn't been today the last
couple of decades yeah I do is it's yeah
I think we kind of went from a place
where there were a whole bunch of things
that we were trying to become more
tolerant of and then we got to the place
where we were more tolerant of a whole
bunch of stuff and now we're at a place
we're on the other side where now you're
no longer choose even savings that were
the norm 20 or 30 years ago
it's like flipped on it it's it's it's
very weird to me and there's certain
things that I think you just you can't
say without all sorts of bad things
coming down on your head if you had to
sort of grade the way the system is kind
of functioning right now we're broken
we're broken I've been saying that for a
while and we're just we're broken I do
think we're talking with a Electoral
College little bit I think that is one
thing that will help I do think we've
been broken before and we've come out of
it we were broken in the years after the
Civil War it was a big mess then we had
multiple elections where you know the
electoral vote the popular vote did not
match up and there were two elections
where the recorded National popular vote
winner did not win the election there
was year after year where the electoral
map looked really really similar very
closely divided the red areas always
seem to be red and the blue here is OECD
blue which is what we're doing now and
eventually because of the electoral
college we came out of that is my belief
because if you think about it if you're
a Democrat in the South in those years
you cannot win the White House at all
period because you don't have enough
electoral votes in your safe areas but
if you are a Republican you kind of have
the opposite problem where you have
enough in the north northwest which is
where it generally was to win but kind
of just barely and if the Democrats make
any inroads at all you're going to lose
so both sides over time had to reach out
to the other side and
and figure it out and so that's why I
think we're there now I do think that's
what's happening but I also have hope
that this because of the structure the
system even though we're not educated
enough about it that we will come back
to a better place where we just have to
figure it out all right so before we do
the full dive on our act or college
which will we'll spend the rest of the
conversation talking about because I
really really want people to understand
why the founders started this idea and
why it actually is the right idea and
all that but in terms of the system
working or not working at the moment do
you think part of it is just that the
way we operate that that the presidency
the cult of personality around the
presidency is such that people think
that it's the president's job to do
everything so they if you if you like
Trump you kind of think oh he should
just do whatever he wants an executive
actions are okay the same time when
Obama's for you probably weren't for
executive actions or right now listening
to the candidates you know the
everything that they want to do they
don't realize they're actually not the
ones that are supposed to write the laws
they're just posed to sign the laws do
you think that that's just a cult of
personality issue that we just pick one
person it almost like we yearn for a
king and like some really perverse sense
or something like that so to really get
geeky on you they're all they up to 17th
amendment which of course changed the
way that we elect the United States
senators and it used to be that state
legislators would pick those and now of
course we have a popular election almost
like anybody else which makes senators
more like the House of Representatives
which is not what they were supposed to
be they were supposed to actually
represent the state right as a state in
the sit in the Congress so that the laws
in the process and all of the stuff that
was happening in Congress would reflect
the interest not only of the people from
the house side but also the state
legislatures which are expected of
course to be an important check and
balance on the national government well
unsurprisingly when we turn the Senate
into something more like the house we if
we lost a check and now it's the
Congress has just become a place to try
to get the people as much as we feel
like we want you know whether it's good
for the country whether it's good for
the state or not and so that has but
then also it's hard it's Congress I
think they defer like they they push it
off into an administrative a
they delegate power to the president or
they they do these different things to
be able to give as much as they possibly
can without always having to be as blunt
about it as maybe they would have to be
otherwise so before the 17th amendment
did things function a little bit
differently because they they were
chosen by their own States they had to
come back and deal with their own state
said yes there's the United States
Senator before the 17th amendment and
you vote for a bill that includes an
unfunded state mandate go you're right
you're not gonna get reelected or not
the state legislature is gonna be really
mad at you yeah so you're accountable to
just a different set of people which is
healthy because it that and you know or
say the federal government wants to take
power in some area what whatever it is
you know they change the drinking age
and federal funds for roads went along
with that but if you're a state senator
and you know that your state a United
States Senator and you know that your
state legislature prefers to be in
charge of its own roads you're not gonna
vote for that bill it's just it changed
the dynamics completely and made it much
much easier for the federal government
to swoop in and take over from the
states on a whole variety of issues but
I think it also made it easier for the
Congress to delegate to the President or
to an administrative agency or there was
just less accountability overall for any
of this and of course the more power the
president's delegated exactly what
you're saying happens yeah we think the
president the president has become such
an all important elected official in so
many ways that didn't used to be true
yeah all right so with all that in mind
and let's do electoral college 101 where
did the idea of the electoral college
first come from well the delegates to
the Constitutional Convention spent the
whole summer going back and forth
should we have a national popular vote
just like people went now should we do
something else they and they had crazy
ideas maybe we'll have three presidents
maybe what and they talked about
legislative selection that was one of
the main ideas on the table
maybe we'll have Congress elected
president they talked about governor
selecting the right they had a whole
bunch of ideas but the to defy Diaz that
were there at the end the primary ones
were national popular vote and Congress
picks the president
nobody knows exactly what happened
because there was a committee for
unfinished business and they went behind
closed doors and there's some things
haven't changed that much so there was
one report that James Madison took a pen
and paper and sketched out the idea they
came back and presented to the whole
convention the convention was surprised
that they had deviated from national
popular vote but this is what this is
what they decided on and it solved the
concerns of the big versus small states
that have been going back and forth the
whole summer the big states by and large
were more comfortable with national
popular vote idea the small states were
really uncomfortable they thought they
would be terrorized and there's a great
quote from a Delaware deglet delegate
and he says I do not trust you gentlemen
if you have the power he's a gentleman
which i think is funny I do not trust
you it's like underlined in italics your
gentlemen if you have the power the
abusive it could not be chapped and you
would exercise it to our destruction and
that's what the small states felt that
we will be destroyed yeah if you have
this kind of a system in place and I
think it's important to note by the way
that the divide here with not slave
versus not slave it was small versus
large and there were some large states
that had you know more more slaves than
not and there were in vice versa in the
same thing with a small state some had
slaves some didn't it was not a slave
versus not slave divided it was a small
versus large were there any reps say
from big states that actually were for
the electoral college because that would
have been giving power away but we do
know that a lot of the founders were
trying to curtail that vowel so James
Madison Virginia and I think he was more
comfortable in the beginning with just a
national popular vote but he he came he
felt like this was a better compromise
in the end obviously he sketched it out
behind closed doors right now when
people say and we're hearing this more
and more we should just have the popular
vote that you know the current president
lost the popular vote he's an
illegitimate president what is the
counter-argument I really wish people
would stop and just think about why the
Democratic Party lot the people who are
upset on the Democratic side because
they lost they've spent a lot of time
blasting the system and criticizing the
system criticizing Trump and I wish they
would spend more time thinking
about why they lost and the reason they
lost is because Hillary Clinton spent
too much time doing exactly what the
Electoral College does not want her to
do or any candidate to do which is she
focused too exclusively on one kind of
voter this kind of voter that happens to
live in big cities in New York and
California mostly she got 20% of her
vote from only New York in California
and most of her vote in those two states
came from the big cities towards the end
of the campaign she people don't usually
know this but she thought she was about
to win the electoral vote and lose the
popular vote so she actually doubled
down on that strategy and she started
spending a lot of time and resources on
safe areas areas that she was already
expected to do up because she wanted to
drive up the popular vote in those safe
areas so that she would not have that
discrepancy but between the electoral in
the popular vote but of course she did
said gone to Wisconsin Michigan
Pennsylvania spread out her base of
Appeal built coalition's worked on that
she she probably would have won it was
within reach and she could have done it
but she didn't so is the main argument
then that basically you will create a
situation where a state like California
which has what like the tenth biggest
economy in the world or something like
that is huge population it's a huge land
mass and then New York with a huge huge
population concentrated in big cities
that if we get rid of the electoral
college that almost everything but
especially the middle of the country
will just be completely ignored by the
federal government so it's the same it's
the same issue from from 200 years ago
right right I mean if you're a candidate
you have limited time you have limited
resources that's just human that's not
good or bad it's just what it is and you
cannot physically cannot go everywhere
you cannot it's not productive or
efficient to try to strategize how to
bring in people from different parts of
the country what is most productive as a
purely strategic matter is just to go to
where people already like you and just
start drumming up support I mean if
you're a Republican maybe you go to
Houston and you look at the oil interest
and you say I'll give you this I'll give
you that I'll give you this and you just
try to drum up as many people as you can
if you're a Democrat maybe you say I'm
gonna give the environmental law
be everything they want I'm gonna go to
LA and San Francisco I'm gonna start
drumming up support there I'll ban
plastic straws in the whole country or
something I don't know it's so it's just
it is just practical it's not even
malevolent or anything at all it is just
what it is it is a huge big diverse
country and if you don't give candidates
a reason to care they're not going to
what would you say to the people that
would just say tough that we should do
this by how many people vote for
somebody and you know what if you live
in Missouri in a small town that's tough
you don't live in a big city but the but
but the big city person's vote doesn't
count less than yours you know it's just
it's so interesting to me the people
people think that because they're there
is not any other context where we would
just say tough you know we wouldn't say
if one race can outvote the other race
tough you know we can do it everyone
nobody would say that we shouldn't say
that so why is it okay to say yeah if
the big city people out vote the farmers
who cares i I don't think that's right I
think what's right is to create a
society that is just and and to do our
best to take into account a wide need
wide variety of needs and if you think
about it I mean if you let the big
cities dictate to the farmers where they
do most of the producing in this country
by the way you're telling the people who
are the end users that they can
tyrannize over the producers that's
gonna create a really bad situation we
see this in California all the time if
you drive up the coast where all the
farmers are complaining about water
rights and then the big cities are
getting all the water and it's like guys
they're the ones growing the food right
does anyone care about the food so you
have these dynamics in the states it's
in New York too it's in a couple of
other states and it's in Texas really I
why do we think that we can change the
system and that these problems that
already exist at the state level will
not happen
yeah the national level of course they
will so I've actually long said I think
California Texas a handful of the big
states for their governor should have an
electoral college kind of thing going on
I think it would be it would produce
better governance in the big states
interesting so you would take an
electoral college
concept and apply it even to those big
states because that way you could sort
of control their need to just serve the
the big you know Dallas farmers be
tyrannize by the people in the big
cities why should people and you know in
the middle of Texas where there's you
know very small population cities why
should they be terrorized by I live in
Dallas but why should they be terrorized
by us in Dallas or in Houston or San
Antonio or Austin they have different
needs and concerns and I you know I'm
not sure the gubernatorial process is
always reflect that so I know that we
don't know everything that went on in
these meetings where James Madison
sketching this all Apple where did all
the numbers come from well the numbers
come from Congress so you have the same
number electors as you do members of the
House plus your two senators so that is
true for every single state that's how
I'm from Texas we have 38 electors
that's we have 36 congressmen plus two
senators so these can change over time
right they do change everything yes and
does that how does that affect the way
everybody's drawing up demographic Maps
and all kinds of stuff well I mean it's
really just based on the census and so
if you have and it's based on after the
census they decide how many people
aren't going to be in the house and then
we reallocate the electors just to match
it so do you feel that the system is
actually functioning as it should then
even if even if the people aren't being
as responsible and maybe don't know
civics the way you would want them to
and all of those things do you think
that the basic election system and
especially again because we're rolling
into an election we're gonna hear about
election rigging we're gonna hear about
foreign influence we're going to hear
about popular vote for its electoral
college but do you think that the
elections are basically safe and secure
and that this is sort of the best way
that they can operate yeah I do am look
I think we're a mess right now I think
both parties are being really super
stubborn about fixing themselves I think
pretty much everybody could do a better
job of working to build coalitions and
it being inclusive and trying to
understand the people that don't fall in
line exactly well you know where I am
and until we figure that out it's going
to look like this I hope I hope
we figure it out sooner as I'm kind of
tired of it as everybody else is but the
system is not not working and the reason
we're having closed elections is because
everybody's being stubborn like I said
what happened after the silver war it is
the irony here though that if the states
would actually take back some of the
rights that they've been sort of
outsourcing to the federal government
that none of this would matter that much
right because you the presidency would
have less power so that really is the
that to me strikes me as the answer all
right like you keep as much as you can
local and then it won't matter that much
what the what the executive branch can
do and if the states were back in charge
then there would be less for the judges
to do which means the judicial
nominations would be less of a tear you
know less of an employee I think people
are just so worried that their preferred
policy preference on whatever it is it's
going to get decided by judicial
nominations or by the president or by
you know and so it becomes so important
and it's the system that was created by
the founders it's very decentralized
there should never be that much power in
one place there shouldn't be that much
power in the Supreme Court or the
presidency it shouldn't it should be
spread out and if it were yeah exactly
what would there be to be who why would
it be mad anything you know why would a
Texan care what a California decided
about straws as it shouldn't matter
efficient yeah what do you make of the
executive action portion of this what do
you think the founders would be saying
about the way we govern we're you know
and again everybody does it so this is
not a this is not a partisan thing both
sides GWB did it too and then and then
Obama reverse still out of it and now
Trump reversed a lot of that I mean
that's a really dangerous way to govern
right I agree completely and it it I I
see it all the time and I wish it
weren't happening I wish that people
cared enough to say something to explore
to call their congressmen and say you
know go take that back that power that
just got usurped from you to go take it
back you think it's maybe that
everything seems to be more about optics
than the way things are supposed to be
governed like you never hear anybody
talk about well you know I can't say
never I say you yet
guy like Rand Paul maybe and Mike Lee
from your home state like a couple guys
that will actually talk about the
Constitution and things like that did
you see that moment during the the
debate when they were asking Kamala
Harris about confiscating guns via
executive action and Joe Biden said it
has to be constitutional which of course
is the correct answer and Kamala
basically laughed at him and said Joe
can't we just say yes we can like this
this terribly smug answer meaning
because what she's saying is I will take
whatever power I can to literally take
away one of your the second Billa right
I again I think it goes back to not
knowing history because if we knew our
history what we would know is that
British when they were trying to put you
know keep us down the first thing they
did was we went after our guns and our
ammunition and that's why the shots were
fired at Lexington and Concord the
British were marching to go take it and
we said no you can't do that
and it's it happened oh it actually
happened in several cities Lexington and
Concord is the one we know about from
her history books but there were several
places in in 7576 where the British were
trying to take our arms and ammunition
because they knew we wouldn't be able to
put up a fight without it and so the
founders when they created our
Constitution it was one of the most
important things to them they felt like
our Liberty is protected when we can
protect ourselves and it's it's not only
about hunting you know it's about
protecting your Liberty and you know
people like to laugh at that I guess and
say well you our arms don't match the
armies and you know I I guess that's
true but at the time of the founding the
arms that it's not like they had cannons
on their farms you know I mean that's
right some well-armed people that are
really committed to protecting what's
there but again you see examples of the
British there was the Battle of Fells
Point in New York
the British were they had trouble
because there was literally a colonist
behind every bush with a rifle and they
were just having trouble and it changed
their strategy and it changed what they
were doing and so and it actually they
got those people that were behind the
bushes and stuff they delayed the
so so much that George Washington's army
got away that's the outcome of that
story but you just if you know your
history and you know what happened in
the Revolution and you you see these
stories what you see is a founding
generation that knew the government
cannot be the only one with arms and so
that's why they created the Second
Amendment all right so what another
thing that people always talk about with
elections is that now we're in a
position where we know that certain
states are basically always gonna be
blue or in one right now states are
pretty much close to always be in red
you live in one in Texas although that
one's even getting a little a little
iffy these days but that now we're
putting so much pressure on these few
swing states so Ohio Pennsylvania
Florida things like that do you see a
risk in that that then they do it's
almost like an overcorrection where they
pretty much ignore like if Democrats
like well I've got California in the bag
forget California and then I'm gonna
spend all my time focusing on these
three other states I'm not one who
thinks that red states a red and blue
states stay blue I think that there are
periods of time
where there is a stretch and that might
happen but if you look at California as
recently as 1988 you guys voted for
George HW Bush that wasn't that long ago
really and you can look at any if you
look at the whole history of states
voting what you really see are states
that well let me back up I also don't by
then the idea that only swing states
matter safe states are important like
you just said no Democrat wants go in
the election without California it's
back pocket so what do they do to make
California have happy it has to do with
the governance it has to do with the
laws that are mean California is happy
and blue because it's happy with what
Democrats have been doing an office for
the four years that preceded the
election and when they start to become
unhappy they're gonna let people know
pretty pretty quickly right I don't even
know that they're happy in this state
anymore I think it's just like oh we're
blue were blue that that's just kind of
how it is and then and the Republicans
here who I've talked to some of them are
just so defeated they're like we're
trying so hard we're watching our state
crumble and high taxes and more homeless
people and more drugs on the streets and
all this stuff but they're just kind of
throwing their hands up like we've just
lost so many times in a row no I always
wonder what would happen if people just
Oded without regard to how they felt
about it
for every state like what if all the
Democrats came on Texas it did assume
that they were gonna lose right came out
what if all the Republicans came out in
California didn't assume they were gonna
lose just just came out just came out
happen but also if you look historically
you can find lots of examples of states
that just changed unexpectedly or they
threatened to change and the parties
reacted at Utah in 2016 was threatening
of a third party okay so they were just
unhappy they're ready yeah and Mike
Pence was dispatched to the state to
make things right
because Republican Party did not want to
lose its small safe little red state of
Utah in 2000 West Virginia flipped they
flipped because they became really
unhappy with the environmental policies
of the Democratic Party and they swung
the election we all focus on Florida
mm-hmm but without West Virginia there
was no way that george w bush was going
to win that election so a safe small
state flipped and changed everything and
you can you can look through history and
you can see states changing their
allegiance you know back and forth over
time so I tend to say look you know the
safe states matter they just are they
made up their minds earlier in the
process based upon the governance that
came before and swing states are just
late to make up their minds indecisive
and but everybody's important you can't
get to 270 without some combination of
safe and swing states you simply can't
get there so you got to do something to
get them on your side so is there
anything you would do with the way the
Electoral College is set up to tweak it
to tighten it or anything or do you feel
it you feel it's basically as perfect
the system as we can do in a country of
320 million some of my people I I like
it I when I first started this close to
20 years ago there were small things I
would change I thought well maybe we
could automate the Elector you know so
it's not there's no possibility of
elector independence or maybe we could
change the contingent election process
you know where the president selected by
the house if nobody can get a majority
and I thought maybe you could tweak it
but the more I study at the more I look
the more I think this is just a really
delicate balance and if you change one
thing you don't know what kind of domino
effect that might have
and so I would just leave everything I
think it's and it may not be perfect but
it's the best we're gonna do in an
imperfect world I steal something
Winston Churchill said some times and he
said democracy is the worst form of
government except for all the others
I'd say the electoral college is the
worst possible form presidential
election except for all the others that
have been tried right it's it's the best
we can do in a perfect world and it's
got a lot of benefits so this is a
slight deviation from electoral college
specifically but what do you think of
sort of the state of people believing
that the system itself works that the
election process works and is untampered
with and russians and hacking and all of
these things and right just fraud in
general because it seems to me that no
matter what happens in the next election
half the country is gonna claim that it
was illegitimate and we're seeing this
even now I mean just in the last couple
weeks now that Hillary's sort of
reappearing you know she's basically
calling Trump and illegitimate president
because she did win the popular vote as
we talked about so it's like it seems to
me that we that again comes to the
optics part of it where it's like we're
setting up something where half the
country no matter what every four years
is going to think that something illegal
or immoral or awful has happened well
this is what I read observes there's
there's again there's no such thing as
perfection there will always be people
that want to cheat there will always be
people that will look for a way to steal
an election if they can I can't fix that
nobody can fix that the Electoral
College can fix that but what we can do
is we can make it as hard as possible we
got throw up as many hurdles as we
possibly can and if you have a national
popular vote system then what you have
is one centralized national base
database that or you know or just voting
system tabulation whatever you just have
to hack one thing okay you have to and
that means by the way also that you have
to be on defense and every single
precinct of the country so you can be in
the bluest blue California precinct and
your if votes are stolen there you
affect everybody or the reddest red
Texas precinct that vote affects
everybody right now we have a situation
where you don't have to be on defense
absolutely everywhere you just have to
be on defense in a few danger spots
which means you can focus all of your
resources
there and that's better also by the way
if your talk about hacking you it's not
just hacking one national tally you're
you have to actually hack multiple
tallies around the country because there
are 51 different election systems 50
plus DC election systems so you'd have
to identify which one would be you know
the most relevant which state's gonna be
close which state could swing this can i
hack it and you have to be able to do
all it have to have all of these things
working for you before you can actually
steal an election is it impossible but
probably not I'm not gonna claim that
but you again you can make it as hard as
possible and make us that they have to
get through as many hoops as possible
before they can influence you right so
okay so as somebody that obviously you
like states rights and you're trying to
you're trying to set up a system the way
it was originally set to be which is
that you're trying not to give too much
power to the federal government would
you leave the voting mechanisms to the
states or should we have a federal a
federally mandated system of voting
because right now it's like we got
hanging chads in one state we got
electronic voting in another state some
states have receipts after the
electronic voting some states don't and
a zillion other punch cards and a
gajillion different things which that in
and of itself seems really messy I think
one of the most important things that
people don't appreciate or know about
the Electoral College is how important
it is to protect its state's prerogative
just to choose it's to to run its own
election choose its own electors and to
be in charge of itself and maybe the
best way to demonstrate that is to show
what would happen on the opposite side
if we did have one national tally well
what that means is a national election
code an actual national bureaucracy you
know a new presidential appointees it's
for to run this whole thing that you've
put in place and so now you've got a
potentially an incumbent president in
charge of his own election because he's
in charge of the federal machinery that
will make it happen but how it is now
every state makes its own decisions some
states will make better decisions than
others some you know those again it's
like the laboratories of democracy kind
of idea they'll see what works what
doesn't work they'll change every but
everybody will be in charge of
themselves and that by itself as a
protection if we want to isolate one
clip
next time somebody says to me Dave why
do you think the electoral college is
good can you give me like the the sort
of bumper sticker video that we can use
to just push out to people in a couple
minutes like the cleanest clearest
reasoning for the electoral always say
it makes presidential candidates reach
out to a wide variety of voters given
how big and diverse our country is it's
important the founders thought that 13
states was too large and too diverse to
have anything else we're so much bigger
right now and so people say it's
outdated and I say the opposite it's
more important now how can we expect
such a diverse country to govern itself
if we don't have this is the only person
expected to represent all of us the only
one a there are senators that represent
states you know or congressmen that
represent districts everybody else
represents a smaller subset of people
the President must elect the most
liberal person or represent the most
liberal people in California and the
most conservative people in you know
Mississippi or something so it's just
you got to have a special system in
place for that to make him or her take
into consideration as many people as
possible I think I know your answer this
one but would you would you say that our
founding documents are basically the
greatest man man written documents I
think so I think they came they came
together at a special moment in time
they were not perfect people but they
had no partisan interest in the way that
we think of it today there's so many
misperceptions about the founding
generation and it's become so easy to
demonize them it makes me sad I look
they own slaves and they did some things
that we obviously don't want and/or
approve of I think was a big mistake but
also what I think is look they lived at
a moment in time where the king could
tell you what religion to be you know
women couldn't do anything yes there
were slaves but my point is there was a
whole mess of problems and it wasn't
just America it was everywhere and so
our founders did something amazing and
they broke free of part of that and they
said we can be self-governing you can
just make your own mind about religion
and there were some things they got
right and they took an important first
step down the road and we look at them
and we criticized
for not running the whole marathon write
that in there if not yeah it was it was
more like a relay race where they they
ran the first leg and they passed the
baton to the next generation in the next
generation took a little bit further and
what I'm really proud of in America is
that we are always going for more
freedom every generation has done more
and so instead of criticizing the
founding generation I wish we would just
look at them and say thank you for
running the first leg of that race so
well you did great that is how you end
an interview for more on Tara
follow her on the Twitter at Tara Roz if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell